Steel Man String Theory what's awesome
about string what's awesome about string
theory is all the surprises that came
out and strengthened confidence in the
theory I mean getting a Quantum anomaly
cancellation in the theory was very
encouraging and I think that's what
brought Whitten on board when he first
saw that and that really got
steamrolling in popularity also the idea
of just membranes oscillating in higher
dimensions that's a very flexible and
Rich area to investigate both
mathematically and potentially with the
application physics so String Theory did
take advantage of things that had been
very successful like collusion Theory
which is this idea of adding extra
Dimensions to space-time that are
compactified into very small shapes and
letting the strings vibrate in those
Dimensions you're able to get things
that look more like Elementary particles
as excitations
relax